[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar how connected biological safety
cabinets can support your lab best
practices today and future trends
i am marie stone of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of the screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
david phillips nsf accredited bsc field
certifier enhanced
david you may now begin your
presentation
thank you
thanks for allowing me to present this
examination of connectivity on class 2
biosafety cabinets i've been working
with biosafety cabinets for over 40
years first as a with a
service company that service biosafety
cabinets and containment equipment
and then since 2007 with thermo fisher
scientific
i'd like to say there are car people and
music people and food people and of
course more but i'm a bsc person
i find their design performance
manufacturer use
all the people involved endlessly
interesting and so i find this topic of
particular interest as well
so
let's move on and see the next slide
now when we when we talk about
connectivity connectivity is generally
viewed as an inherently good thing
occasionally it bumps up against privacy
or security concerns
but overall we've seen so many benefits
in connection
with our computers and our thermostats
other intelligent devices
with ourselves through social media
that the benefits are so great we want
to connect everything including in this
case our scientific laboratories
next slide
whether it's mobile phone subscriptions
per 100 people the share of the
population using the internet whether
it's in canada the us other countries
around the world
there is this constant trend towards
connection
this trend is not only quantitative it's
qualitative uh what we communicate is
changing as well when we first
years ago we were connected if we knew
what the status of family births and
deaths and just the major life events
now we want to see photos of what our
friends had for dinner dinner and uh and
that that insect they found on their car
next slide
thermo fisher scientific is committed to
becoming the legional leading digital
science company by 2030.
this slide is a visual illustration of
our digital science platform customer
value wheel we see eight technology
segments
these eight technology segments support
two key areas of focus with our
customers increased productivity in the
lab
and scientific acceleration which
supports our mission of enabling our
customers to make the world healthier
cleaner and safer
next slide
now connecting means different things
for different types of laboratory
equipment for connected freezers it
means monitoring the temperature to make
sure our samples are preserved for our
connected pipette aids it means a
standard protocol with sample volumes
and sizes that are able to be shared
through different devices in the
laboratory as well as other locations
last week mike montanaz and i reached
out to mirko spies in our r d center in
near frankfort germany and we were able
to
with use of split screen we we captured
the functioning of our instrument
connect application and website with our
new connected cabinets and so as an
illustration of connection let's take a
look at that now
[Music]
thanks merco for for helping me with
this demonstration today i think it'll
be really helpful to get a sense a
real-time sense of how the interaction
between our app and dashboard and the
cabinet itself so let's start off by you
turning on the cabinet if you would and
let me know when you have it turned on
yes sir
okay it's running
okay so uh
right now our arc this cabinet uh
as kind of the thermoscientific design
uh when the window is closed and the
fans are on the fans are in a reduce
flow standby mode
this allows the cabinet to maintain a
clean and contained work area uh and and
we've seen now on the dashboard that it
has picked up that the uh uh that the
fans are on they're saying that the fans
are in reduced flow so the next thing
we're going to do uh uh mirko if you
could raise the window to operational
height
yes sure
and let us know when it's there
now you'll see you'll typically see a
difference between the uh
[Music]
right
uh so so we see a difference between the
app and the dashboard the app uh tends
to respond a little bit quicker uh but
the dashboard has more detail
and so um
we've seen
excuse me so so we'll see the
uh
when it when it shows up we'll see that
the window is uh the window is open um
i'm showing
are you the window right now is in the
correct position merco
it's in correct position and we are
waiting uh for the okay state now great
okay so uh the the dashboard is already
showing that the window is open
um the
there's a there's a typically a delay
of a minute or so for the airflow to
come up to full speed and to stabilize
so it's ready now
okay and then when that happens you'll
see uh the app will show
that the airflow is okay
and then the dashboard will show that
the airflow is okay and the window is
open
great so now
let's take a look at the
dashboard
so uh
let's go to the dashboard
mike if you could change it to that and
in the dashboard you'll notice
it tells you a lot about the
cabinet it gives you the the firmware
update
at the last update it gives you the
serial number of the cabinet and things
like that
which is very helpful it just presents a
snapshot so you'll notice on the
dashboard it's showing that the lights
are off for instance and the receptacles
are off uh if we turn the receptacles on
and uh mirko could you energize the
receptacles on the cabinet yes sure
it's on
uh that's not immediately seen on the
dashboard but if we refresh the
dashboard you'll see that
that the status of the receptacles will
be updated from off to on so
you you get a sense in working with the
with the
with the dashboard and the apps you need
to be sensitive to what causes the data
to be updated so let's go back to the
dashboard
and now we're going to see uh how the
cabinet handles an alarm
so right now we're seeing on both the
app and the dashboard
that the uh airflow is okay
and the sash position is working uh and
the fan is on so mirko if you could put
uh papers across the front this is just
a way for us to simulate uh an airflow
problem
and uh
for demonstration purposes
and what we're going to be looking for
is uh how that is reflected uh with the
app and with the dashboard
and yeah americans let us know when you
see the airflow on your end and then we
can kind of see
that again there's a typically a lag 30
seconds 60 seconds something like that
for it uh to appear in the summary and
the notifications on the dashboard and
then also
it'll show up in the event log once we
clear it
i have the alarm now
okay
and uh uh
this alarm we have it at the cabinet
we'll be seeing it on the app and the
website shortly
if not already
good and then uh
now that now that we we now that
we see the alarm give
one more second for that and then we'll
go ahead and remove the papers and
see the recovery
okay so we have the alarm again
okay now go ahead and
remove the papers
and what we'll see uh it will take a the
cabinet needs a few moments to recover
um with the removed restrictions the fan
will kind of overshoot and then come
back to standard airflow let us know
when we have good airflow at the cabinet
now we are good again
good so the cabinet is showing good uh
and we'll see that reflected in the
in the dashboard and the
app
okay uh thanks mirko appreciate it um
and um
greetings to you from wonderful uh the
u.s
we'll talk to you later
bye okay no problem you're welcome
the lack of smoothness on that although
for uh my friends will know that lack of
smoothness has never been something that
has been limited uh for me uh moving on
to the next slide
moving on to the next slide
sorry go go back to where we were uh
maggie perfect um we see four levels are
types of connectivity we've got
monitoring where we're able to look at
the connected cabinet and see its status
we could even look for past airflow
alarms with this application
with connected pipette aids we actually
have control we're not directly while
we're not directly controlling the
pipette aids we're able to shape its use
with standard protocols
and via downloaded
downloaded connections
optimization builds on control by using
data from monitoring and interaction of
control to optimize uh the the device
and its interaction with multiple
devices for cabinets we saw a little of
this
or we could see a little of this because
there's they have alerts for upcoming
service needed
this would allow a facility manager to
coordinate third-party service provider
visits
more exciting for us might be the bsc
sensing someone entering the lab and
starting up its fans
to be ready and operational for when
they're ready to use it not something we
can do now
but something but optimization could
allow the equipment in the lab to work
together
more efficiently
finally there's autonomy
there are hints of this in some of the
automated
systems that do automated ordering to
maintain supply maintain supplies of and
consumables
in the future this could be even more
exciting we could have labs that that
track usage of different equipments
within the lab and proposes ways to
avoid bottlenecks
labs that know what other maintenance is
occurring in the building and tries to
coordinate things
but as we start talking about our
laboratory equipment knowing things data
security becomes more significant next
slide
this is an area of transitional thinking
in the old days your data was safest on
your personal computer with an air gap
however over time that air gap becomes
increasingly inconvenient we want to get
emails we need to share files we need to
do research on electronic databases we
try to keep the separation but gradually
it evolves to just trying to limit our
exposure perhaps avoiding some websites
and apps with known tracking
capabilities
during this time malicious
intrusions are escalating we hear about
and maybe even experience ransomware
attacks
we need to constantly update virus and
malware protection on our computers
protecting our computers becomes a
full-time job and we already have
full-time jobs
next slide please
nowadays it turns out that
your data is more secure in protected
cloud storage than on our non-encrypted
laptop at home
thermo fisher connect is hosted by an
amazon web services data center that has
achieved the highest
levels of ssae 16 certification
and has a published service organization
one report
the data is encrypted in transit and in
storage no personal information or
information on research is stored
but data security is a moving target
whatever it takes to be secure today it
will take more tomorrow by partnering
with aws and building a significant
internal resource we're able to provide
an expertise and equipment to protect
these services going forward
we're just starting on this journey
we're a little past that moment 50 years
ago
when cell phones started to gain
popularity at that point we just thought
they were mobile telephones but now they
remember our steps and where we parked
the car
and they helped us find friends back
then we had no idea how far that device
would go
i think similarly the connected lab is a
future place uh yet to be understood
next slide please
for cabinets there are three general
aspects or types of connectivity
when we think about safety cabinets
workflow support
integration with building management
systems
and process monitoring
next slide please
for those of us
with alexa siri or google home we're
already familiar with the idea behind
workflow support
in 2007
in 2007 the federal demonstration
partnership estimated that 42
of american researchers time is spent on
administrative tasks
versus 18 20 years before
regulatory compliance a part of that
administrative responsibility is
consuming more and more resources but
what if we could reduce that trend what
if we could harness the advances in
digital support and move a lot of these
scientists performed administrative
tasks
to a sort of digital lab assistant and
this could reduce the current burden on
laboratory scientists by up to 25
percent
next slide please
there's already movement in this
direction with automated ordering and
supply management software
there are a number of compliant support
programs available
this is analogous to the introduction of
digital technology to the office where
it helped people type documents through
word processing do calculations through
spreadsheets and manage lists and files
with database management systems
you've seen our instrument connect
program for the biosafety cabinet those
and other services for other products
will continue to expand
to other products applications and
greater capabilities
for me a key next step in the lab will
be more user interfaces within the lab
when we're sitting at a biosafety
cabinet and can speak to the system
when we can say hey igor
make sure i have enough buffer for
tomorrow and the digital interface says
yes master
next slide please
uh and igor starts to get smarter or
more observant igor sees you enter the
building and starts up the cabinet
you're scheduled to use igor watches
your hand movements processing the
samples and based on the degree of
hazard in the work signals you to slow
down
igor knows the protocols and monitors as
the laboratories work through the
processes igor anticipates equipment
needs and head-on heads off bottlenecks
as we become more familiar with igor and
igor becomes more familiar with us
and gets to know siri and alexa in the
cloud more advanced systems become more
engaged in the science of what we can do
recording results analyzing results
down the road monitoring publications
for relevant new
findings but for now let's go to one of
the uh to a different application one
that's probably maybe the first
applications building management systems
next slide please
in 1883 warren johnson invented the
thermostat really just the light that
would go on in the boiler room that
would tell the attendants when to shovel
more coal into the furnace
and officially kicked off the idea of
automatically controlling building
systems next
slide over time more building systems
acquired automation for instance
lighting and security
we realized it would be helpful to
integrate these systems to gain greater
efficiencies for instance dimming the
lights in public areas and reducing the
amount of heating or cooling to
non-occupancy
one of the key drivers towards this
integration was energy conservation and
that remains the focus of many bms
systems
however it's not simple to effectively
capture bsc energy use within a building
let me explain next slide please
bsc and energy use have three dimensions
first we have the what state the bsc is
on is in in 2008 the university of
michigan compared one of their new
energy efficient biosafety cabinets to
three of the typical cabinets at the
time
the energy consumption you can see the
energy consumption varies with the
cabinet see in the first row
cabinet a consumes 841 watts while the
dc motor unit uses less than a fourth as
much
the second dimension is use different
states on off or reduced flow
lights on or off uv germicidal lights on
or off all of these consume energy
differently
notice that for the same cabinet on our
chart the use can go from over 800 watts
in use with the lights on to zero when
not in use
one dimension is the cabinet the second
dimension would be the state of the
cabinet
what's the third
it's time these the status the the
states change over time we know cabinets
vary due to model with type and more
we know individual cabinets vary
depending on how we are using them the
third dimension is how much time is
spent in each state an energy hog of a
cabinet that's only used for an hour a
day will consume less energy than an
energy efficient cabinet that's in
constant use particularly if that
constant use maybe not it may not be
necessary
we cannot ask what is the energy
consumption without asking how much it
is used and how it is set up when it's
not in use
next slide
in 2011 we inter we surveyed
approximately 90 bscs at a north
american university this is a graph with
how many hours per week the cabinets
were used on the horizontal axis
against how many hours per week the
biosafety cabinets were operating on the
vertical axis
we can see there are basically two types
of users falling on two lines
next slide please
of the people across the top we'll call
them super operators that leave the
cabinet on all the time whether or not
they're using it and this is not an
uncommon or unknown trend when it comes
to biosafety cabinets some people feel
they should leave them on all the time
even when they're not using it
also notice there are sig and notice
there are significant numbers of people
in this group
we also have the people along the
slanted lines that we'll call a la carte
users in general they have the cabinet
on when they're using it and turn it off
when they're not using it
when we track energy usage whether we
realize it or not we're looking at these
two different types of users it will
take more than a bms system to manage
that energy use
we're going to need to find out what
usage policy and practices are in place
and engage there
next slide please
this is a summary
building on the idea this is a summary
of the annual cost of operation of over
the of the over 800 units we have
surveyed at various locations we
measured the energy consumption and
different states for each of the
cabinets we interviewed the users to
find out how much they use them in each
of the different states and then we
multiply those hours by the different
rates of energy consumption and combine
it with the cost of exhaust when
applicable
other than noticing the significance of
external exhaust
the red and yellow are exhausted
cabinets notice the variation from a low
of less than fifty dollars per year to
almost eight thousand dollars per year
for our building management system
dashboard we could track energy use and
such but for some cabinets it would be
insignificant relative to the cost of
the building
but if we had enough of the costly
cabinets it might make sense but
remember costly as a function of both
the cabinet itself and the use of the
cabinet
the reason we went into this detail is
to point out that effectively using
bsc energy information provided to a
building management management system
will require engagement with usage
safety and environmental policies and
procedures
it could be challenging for some
cabinets but not an or not really worth
the time let's take a look at an example
next slide please
using the survey data will make a
boatload of assumptions and kind of an
imaginary building with a hundred
biosafety cabinets again just to get a
sense of how it might look
so we have a hundred bio safety cabinets
eleven of them are class two type b2
cabinets which have high exhaust
19 are canopy a2s which have some
exhaust and the remaining 70 cabinets
are vented to the laboratory
we're going to assume that 70 of the bsc
users are those a la carte users and 30
are the super operators
we're also going to assume that the
average weekly use of the cabinet is
17.6 hours we got that from the survey
which we presented at the cdc
sustainability symposium in 2012
and then we're going to assume an
average cost of electricity of 11.29
cents per kilowatt hour and a cost of
exhaust of 4.50 per cfm per year
if we come up with the total cost of the
annual cost of that population of 100
biosafety cabinets
it turns out if we had a way to at 10
o'clock every night
that any cabinet left in operation would
be automatically shut down theoretically
we could save almost half of the total
cost of energy for those 100 cabinets or
over 20 thousand dollars
there are a lot of things buried in that
if should we turn a cabinet off remotely
uh well maybe if we give it lots of
warning if it doesn't turn completely
off it rather closes the window and goes
into a standby
feminist and containment
there are many people that hate this
idea but i have to tell you i get the
question every couple years
another issue is security there are some
users including government and pharma
users who are very sensitive to the flow
of information outside the physical
plant
you can see the security concerns on one
side but we also see the benefits of
continued manufacture engagement with
some equipment users of apple iphones
and ipad get regular messages saying hey
we're going to update the software on
your device tonight and it's mostly a
good thing they correct vulnerabilities
in the system and add new features
i don't know how all these issues will
get resolved but i do think the
advantages to connecting this overall
that's there be some sort of
accommodation or a way forward to be
identified
next slide
back to building management systems
it's not uncommon for building
management systems to try to go beyond
energy conservation they would like to
identify or even predict equipment
failure
here i'd like to introduce a term
attendant operation
on the left is a photo of a freezer farm
and on the right is a biosafety cabinet
one obvious difference is the cabinet is
that the cabinet has a person sitting at
it
almost all the bio safety cabinet's
purpose is fulfilled with a purse
working with a person working in the
cabinet
unlike freezers the biosafety cabinet
has attended operation
um
freezers incubators and some other types
of equipment provide much of their value
working while unattended for these
devices an unintended and automated
system to monitor this unattended
operation is tremendously helpful there
are systems allowing these devices to
call you at home warning of failure or
other critical condition this can allow
your organization to preserve important
samples
in contrast most of the biosafety
cabinet alarms and alerts are intended
for the person working at the biosafety
cabinet we have window position alarms
to tell you
to remind you to put the window back in
operating position before you start
using it
we have airflow alarms signaling when
there's disruptions in the air flow like
we saw with our video with mirko
but you may not need to be called at
home to let you know that your friend at
work is going through these alarms
in the future we may begin using
cabinets in a different way in an
unattended way
as some sort of ventilated clean storage
i don't see that but i remember back in
the day i didn't understand why we
needed cameras on our phones and i was
wrong there
but for now it's important to note that
almost all biosafety cabinet use is
attended and there's greatly reduced
need for remote monitoring as we already
have a trained person at the device
they need to know what's going on but
it's less so for somebody at the
facility's control room
but if we did monitor it what could we
monitor
next slide please
is an example from our class 2 type b2
bsc
we have a usb port on the cabinet you
can select whether it outputs this
string of data every second every 10
seconds 30 seconds or a minute
the first 11 characters or so give the
equipment status you know what's on
what's off window position alarm status
fan speed setting the remaining
characters give rpm airflow sensor data
inflow and downflow velocities
very nice but remember again this is an
attended device people are interacting
with them it's the sash not at working
height because somebody bumped into it
and is ignoring the alarm and is
continuing to work so we should do
something or do they're just are they
just raising the window so that they can
more easily load in supplies or clean
the work area
tracking some of this information over
time can almost reduce its value
if we detect an alarm and can look and
ask the user if everything's okay that's
great
but if we find out that we had a window
position alarm that came on 10 o'clock
in the morning yesterday well what can
we really do with that
if we see the fan is
fan rpm is zero but the fan is on we
could see that's a problem
but what what other than that what other
types of data can we parse out of the
rpm and other sensor data
just as a side point bsc fans don't fail
very frequently cabinets seem to run
relatively well there may not be
a large need to
predict failure if failures aren't that
common
i'm not saying there's no value here i'm
saying we need to think about it a
little uh what should we track what do
we want to do with the information
and then how we how should we proceed
in contrast our freezer group has this
great technology that monitors and
anticipates compressor failures that's
like that's an ideal example you have
these massive freezer farms with
valuable samples running constantly with
nobody watching them it's a great fit
for this technology
for bsc the value may not be as high
moving on our third variant of
connectivity is process monitoring and
to lay the groundwork for that i want to
walk over to this cabinet here and
demonstrate cleanliness and containment
so with the biosafety cabinet
the
if you're using biosafety cabinet in the
process monitoring
there you probably want a couple things
first the gmp customers want uh a clean
environment now this is uh this is a
class ii type a2 cabinet i have a
particle counter set up here to beep the
air inside is
100 000 times cleaner than the air
outside but you can't see that but with
the aid of this helpful particle counter
i'll turn it on
and as it begins to pull the particles
from the air it's going to begin to beep
and that's just the normal stuff that's
in the air now if i place it in the
cabinet
it disappears so they're out here this
is probably an iso class 8 iso class 9
environment in there it's an iso class 5
quite possibly cleaner
most process monitoring is required for
gmp type customers cell therapy type
customers
and these customers
first want that the work area be clean
the iso class 5 clean
and that's and they get that
with the hepa filters inside the cabinet
the second feature that a cabinet
provides that you don't get from a clean
bench
or
a clean bench or a horizontal flow bench
could you give me some smoke
uh
is containment it's not just that the
air the air in here is cleaner than the
air out here the really cool thing about
a biosafety cabinet is that the air in
here cannot get out here so
let me turn off my
beeper
good
so the air in here is clean and so you
notice with the smoke
it cannot get into the cabinet
that's kind of what we expected that's
how it stays clean in there and even
though it's dirty out here
but the exciting thing is is when we
look at
can the air in there get out here
and notice
it's not
that anything inside the cabinet
is staying inside the cabinet the value
of a class 2 biosafety cabinet in most
process monitoring for gmp and cell
therapy type applications is that it's a
clean and contained area also notice the
smoke it's kind of a lot so you can see
a lot but notice
even though i'm releasing smoke here
it's not quite getting everywhere the
nature of the bio safety cabinet with
the uniform downflow is it tends to
limit the ability of contamination to go
from one part of the cabinet to the
other
so let me
go ahead and have this turned off
and then we'll go back and take out uh
and continue on the presentation and
look at the requirements
under uh
annex one of the of gmp
give me the next slide please
so it turns out that pharmaceutical
manufacturing and per cap perhaps other
applications require process monitoring
and for example here we see in pages
three and four of the european
commissions
annex one with guidelines for the
production of sterile medicinal products
we find we need to monitor the
cleanliness of the air remember that was
one of the things that we needed the
most and that's usually done with
particle monitoring like we did
for the full duration of critical
processing so when you're doing the the
sensitive step of preparing the drug or
whatever
you need to monitor the air cleanliness
the the other thing is is that
if they if we just needed a clean
environment we would probably just use a
clean room or horizontal flow bench
because we want a bio safety cabinet we
want that containment so if we're going
to monitor the process we also need to
monitor that containment we need to have
some way to monitor that airflow that
balance of inflow and downflow at the
front opening
and how can we do that next slide please
it's not unusual for cabinets to have a
dry or voltage-free contact these were
originally intended to signal an
external exhaust fan
when somebody turns on the exhaust the
bsc fan an external uh
an external fan on the roof would come
on and withdraw it and you would use
this if you had an externally exhausted
class ii type a2 or if you had a one of
the hard ducted cabinets of b1 or b2 and
the idea is when i turned on the fan and
the bsc would automatically turn on this
secondary exhaust fan that i needed
using our cabinets as an example we have
a monitor connection
that will open or close the circuit
whichever you want when the fans are
operational full speed and there are no
alarms activated
as i mentioned in our case we've got a
window position alarm and an airflow
alarm
the airflow alarm will signal when the
inflow is too high or too low or when
the downflow is too high or too low
we also have an external fan connection
that will open or close when the fans
are operational full speed
this allows a user to have an external
fan to come on whenever they want to
turn on the cabinet and open the window
but for gmp given the validated
containment velocities we can use this
function to send a signal when the bsc
velocities
go out of range or when they're in range
and this gives the gmp users the ability
to monitor airflow for containment
different cabinets have different
capabilities but dry contacts are not
uncommon
we can see that to meet regulatory
requirements for process monitoring we
would need to think through in some
detail what these yes no circuits mean
and whether they're helpful enough
additional sensors could be added
velocity sensors could be applied for
inflow and downflow pressure sensors
could check flow across filters for
overall flow
we'd have to be careful in installing
them to make sure we don't breach any
safety barriers
but in general the data from the context
contacts the sensors and particle
counters would need to be captured and
formatted in a helpful way
we could also have a problem in
synchronizing that data with our
attended use cabinet opening the window
beyond operational height is okay for
preparation but not when we're doing the
critical processing so we would need
some way to know when it's being used
for critical processing and when it's
being used for just setup or not in use
at all
again
defining a connected cabinet for process
monitoring
isn't necessarily direct and simple
next slide please
so what
so what can we do with our cabinet today
here are some suggestions on the topic
of biosafety cabinet connectivity
first when the topic comes up i strongly
figure out
i strongly suggest that we figure out
which type that we're talking about
often the tone of these meetings seems
to be you know let's do connectivity
i think we need the context of why we're
pursuing it are we pursuing it for
process monitoring or for bms or for
something else
uh second for bms applications for
energy use energy conservation type
applications can find think about how
you're going to capture
the use data
i know i'm often asked for data
connectivity of little value yes we can
put in a pressure sensor yes we can put
in uh you know something else
but is that really going to help you
figure out how the cabinets being used
as far as energy consumption and how it
can be used more effectively
for process monitoring i'm actually a
big fan of process monitoring the
the gmp requirements is that you monitor
all the critical processes we talked
before or showed in the demonstration
that the bsc end of this is probably
the air cleanliness which will be some
sort of particle monitoring
and then the uh the balance of inflow
and downflow or the containment at the
front there will be other things you
need to monitor for your process
depending on the process you know
temperature flow rates you know things
like that but the bsc end of it will
require that cleanliness component in
that uh containment component and we'll
need to think about how we want to
capture that
and then we also have the attended
versus non-attended issue that we need
to address
finally for the exciting future of
workflow support
i think we look forward to the
opportunities it's coming i i don't
think we have a good sense of what it's
going to look like on the other side
more and more devices will be connected
more and more devices
will provide different kinds of data
give us the ability to make different
decisions
and
i i think we just have to have to keep
our eyes open and try to harness
uh try to win the future uh for safety
and containment
uh next slide please
uh so what can we do now well first if
you're interested in doing connection
now think about why
uh
because that that makes a big difference
for
uh for workflow support i would
encourage you to to add capability and
and uh and see what you can do with it
kind of
almost play with the technology and and
learn how to use it more effectively
uh for bms
there has to be a strong linkage into
the policies and procedures of your
facility because that's where a lot of
the energy conservation is going to be
and for for process monitoring
there's a real opportunity in the remote
contacts and and almost all biosafety
cabinets have some sort of remote or dry
voltage contacts so it's quite possible
that there is capability there as long
as we understand it correctly and can
apply it well
so that's the presentation and i look
forward to any questions you might have
thank you david for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q and a
portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
how can i connect an old bsc for process
monitoring
oh thank you yeah like i said the
exciting thing is
there is probably
some sort of rudimentary characteristic
already there for the
uh the airflow piece with the dry
contacts so i would i would dig out the
operator's manual uh you may have to to
play with a little bit to find out
what it shows does it just show the fan
coming on and off
or does it also include some alarm
capability either in that one contact or
alternative contacts
if there is uh if you don't have
anything like that most of the older
cabinets have an ability to uh
it's usually claimed as the ability to
monitor the airflow really it's usually
putting some sort of a velocity sensor
on the exhaust
but that would move you closer to that
and then for the air cleanliness part as
i mentioned you would just tie you would
need some sort of a particle counter
probe placed inside the cabinet many
cabinets today have uh have passages
provided for contained
uh for a way to push a tube and a
contained way to sample from within the
the biosafety cabinet work area so that
would give you the cleanliness part and
the containment part would come through
some sort of
remote contact or perhaps having to buy
an accessory to measure exhaust airflow
would be the easiest way with what you
have now
great thank you
next question
is the data connection to your new
cabinet
21cfr compliant
oh that's a good one
not yet and i think i think a lot of
that's because uh at this point we don't
really store data on the cabinet
uh
the data that comes out of the cabinet
again my my evolving understanding of
the requirements of the of 21cfr
is that
the data needs to be stored in a
protected controlled way and since the
cabinet doesn't do that storage
at this point
the cabinet could reliably pass data to
your 21cfr compliance system and then
from there pick it up i'm sure it'll be
a capability that our systems will be
adding later because there's a high
degree of interest in that
great thank you
next question
we saw what the current workflow support
for bscs offers and understand it will
continue to expand what do you think we
will see next
oh that that's you know that's i i i
mentioned at the beginning i was a bsc
person and that's actually something i
like to think about at night before i go
to sleep you know uh uh because
you know our our phones do so amazing so
many amazing things you know uh i
and and and games and things like that
uh do so many amazing things
i the the the
i think the first round will be very
basic the second round will tend to
uh fill in the holes
uh you know provide uh you know more of
the data stream you saw from the b2 and
and things like that to make it easier
for people who want to capture that kind
of data the third round i think will get
kind of intriguing and for there i'm
looking for
some ability for the user to communicate
to or through the cabinet uh you know a
couple times i mentioned one of the pros
problems with process monitoring is you
can't tell when somebody's working or
when they're just setting up so there's
going to need to be some sort of
way to
provide that data capture that data
whether it's a button you tap before you
start working whether we find some way
the cabinet can tell when you started
working you know like like nowadays with
phones it can tell when you're looking
at it the screen will light up because
it senses that you've moved it in a
certain way
um
so
you know one is just to get started and
we're definitely in that mode two we'll
be kind of filling in the holes uh but
three will be interesting because i
think that's where we'll move into some
interesting territory
great
next question
i am a volunteer cap inspector and i
gave deficiencies for obstruction of the
grids
please what is the clearance standard
for all the safety cabinets thank you
um
[Music]
there okay so so okay i s there's a
couple questions the first question if
you're asking for
uh how much the
front and rear intake grills must be
clear
there's no place
i don't think there's a place that
actually says
you can't put anything on the grills i
think there are a number of places and
if you send me your email i'll be happy
to send them to you
that advise that to say you know
don't put things on the grill it blocks
the air and things like that which would
give you the basis for that kind of
recommendation now if you're asking for
clearance around the cabinet uh the best
kind of authoritative resource for that
in north america is nsf ansi 49
currently i think the 220 version is out
and i think it asks for six to 12 inches
on each side
on top um
i i have to look it up it's it's a
12 to 24 inches
uh in reality that can be checked by the
certifier but for you and your role uh
uh
for as you know seeking kind of overall
generic compliance
you need the standard so so i would
recommend finding the clearances in the
nsf document and like i'd be happy to to
send those to you i don't know if i
remember the exact distances off the top
of my head
great thank you and looks like we have
time for one more question
what are the systems available for
monitoring in the market
uh any self cleaning systems
trying to uh
so i'm i'm
i'm guessing
the question is how to monitor
the
self-cleaning systems inside a cabinet
i'm not sure uh the the standard the
standard way to use a biosafety cabinet
is you need to surface decontaminated on
the inside before you start work and
then once you finish you have to have to
do that again
there are some uh
you
in some pharma applications and and in
some i think i think europe you run into
a little bit
uh
they'll i've heard of occasionally like
fumigation cycles where they'll use
hydrogen peroxide vapor to uh to try to
clean the inside the work area i was
never able to really get a sense of how
common that was
i don't know typically on those they
validate a particular cycle and then
just repeat the cycle versus validating
it each time
yeah i don't know if i have a good
enough understanding of the question to
be able to answer that correctly but
again if you'd like to
provide your email be happy to engage
with you on that sounds like an
interesting topic
great well thank you david do you have
any final comments for our audience
uh no thank you very much i think
biosafety cabinets are a blast i love
talking to people about it so uh
definitely i look forward to seeing you
sometime in the future hopefully in
person stay safe
great you too well thank you again david
for your time today and your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
you